I once knew a young woman who would defy  anyone and anything in order to do what  she felt was right but you're clearly  not her you're broken anything having to  do with Gabriel Krueger we need to save  miles away from I thought that this  would be no you didn't think faith you  never do don't get lost barely out of  prison and already stirring things up  your parents would be proud mr. Krueger  he is out for runner blood whatever it  is you stole from him must be very  valuable  stop  you keep this up I swear you'll be dead  in a month  using every weapon at our disposal we've  got to destroy it back off who did this  he'll be able to do it to anyone unless  he stopped  get out of my sight that is what else is  there you're wrong I'm not broken prove  it  so it's a fighter in you after